school system's already been losing
relevancy in every passing year and this
just might be the straw that breaks the
camel's back what's the supposed purpose
of school well is to teach kids right
supposedly to teach kids teach them how
to learn teach them valuable skills to
prepare them for the real world once
they get out there well what's more
valuable as a skill right now than to
learn how to use Chachi PT and to learn
how to use artificial intelligence
because the kids come out of school my
my 13 year old son included are entering
a very different world than their
parents are
and what is the education system doing
instead of trying to figure out how to
learn chat gbt and teach their students
about chat gbt they're investing their
time and resources to figure out how to
detect and block it
I'm worried what do you think let me
know in the comments below